hallo leute wir drehen heute eine super
easy zufolge über katzen
vielleicht habt ihr auch katzen oder
haustiere und freut euch über das video
vielleicht guckt er auch katzen videos
bei youtube faktors neuen sich schlafen
naja ist noch ganz müde
anton schläft noch
anton leckerchen leckerli anton ist kein
hund
anton hört zwar nicht auf seinen namen
aber er kommt wenn er weiß dass nicht
futter habe
[Musik]
jetzt lockt ich anton auf das sofa anton
ist sein leckerchen
er will mehr
[Musik]
anton wollte mich kratzl er ist sehr
hungrig die katze bekommen jetzt futter
[Musik]
anton ist das futter anton hatten hunger
anton möchte nach draußen
anton möchte wieder rein
warum nutzt er nicht die katzenklappe
will naja ihm helfen
nein
sie möchte ihm nicht helfen
anton geht rein
na ja geht raus naja möchte draußen
bleiben
nun hat anton das haus für sich
er liebt es in der sonne zu liegen
[Musik]
während na ja draußen in der kälte sitzt
das leben ist anstrengend anton macht
einen mittagsschlaf in seinem körbchen
naja ist zurück
anton ist genervt die katzen streiten
sich und rangeln
[Musik]
nach dem streit ist anton wieder lieb
jetzt muss er sich erst mal putzen
ich glaube er hat wieder hunger an toll
frist
naja hat sich auch vom streit erholt sie
lässt sich gerne streicheln
[Musik]
es ist zeit schlafen zu gehen
gute nacht das war unsere folge über
katzen wenn ihr jetzt lust habt noch
mehr deutschen werben zu lernen dann
probiert doch mal unsere apps viel
länger aus dort findet ihr unter anderem
einen vokabeltrainer in den übungen zu
den wichtigsten deutschen nomen werben
und aktiven machen könnt viel spaß dabei
bis bald
[Musik]